well obviously I was in some part
inspired by the Pygmalion myth and about
the sculptor who who falls in love with
his statue is he's making it and then
prays that it will come to life and the
gods grant him his wish and I think that
that myth comes down to us gendered for
a reason that there's a kind of way that
men have a romantic idea or ideal of
women that feels different than the way
that women look at men and so I think I
was writing from that perspective
although not with an agenda necessarily
and can you hear me okay good um and
that like a movie like Annie Hall for
instance that I I think that that's a
amazing movie and that that that woman
feels so real to me but then I start to
ask myself you know that is a woman
being filtered through and man's gaze so
what feels real about it to me you know
is he writing from inspiration or from
aspiration and that that question sort
of filtered through me into the story
but I didn't have an agenda like I said
while writing it we were also attracted
to the idea that all relationships begin
with a certain amount of fiction and and
so while there are very specific issues
about women in film it's also very much
about how relationships evolve and how
they begin and and the issues of control
in any relationship also I think we were
interested in the idea of you know the
relationship that Calvin has just to his
creation and you know the way that we
all try to control the work we're doing
and it's sort of this wrestling with how
much control do you do you really want
to have and then letting it kind of have
a life of its own and those so I think
the fact that those all those issues
were alive and this story is what really
attracted us to it I seen the car and
actually the scene before that in the
kitchen when when we make her speak
French you know that was a that you know
the writing so
eight and so if you follow it you'll
you'll pretty much succeed and
especially with their direction but it
was I think scary for me only because it
was a because Harry is the audience and
in a way in a big way I think and so if
if I screwed that up I thought maybe the
audience would would maybe stop
following this this this belief in Ruby
sparks so it was important we did a
bunch of different takes with the
laughing and being serious and being
scared of her and being amazed and
seeing a ghost and they put what what
I'm happy what they used and Kris makes
those two scenes seem very easy and you
know like of course that's the way you
would react but but trying to figure out
how one would react to a situation which
we never actually encounter in life is
such a challenge you made it so human
and so real and it was just such a gift
to the film and you know it also pulling
the yeah and and the physicality even in
the stuffed in the car was just so
wonderful so when you're dealing with a
fantastic subject matter and there's
certainly fantastic elements in this
movie it's really important in my
opinion to ground it in a recognizable
reality so the audience is immediately
feeling like this is the world that we
live in that this is taking place in and
and it doesn't it think about it and
then they're thinking about the story
and the characters and beyond that there
were things that we wanted to do
specifically to create the reality of
these characters Calvin was a young
writer he had a lot of money at one
point that he got from writing his first
book and he probably lived in a big
house what kind of house was this where
was it we ended up shooting almost
everything in the silver lake in las
filas area which seemed like the kind of
neighborhood he would live in and but
then there were considerations beyond
that we wanted a space that would allow
the actor
to move in a certain way and to develop
the characters in a certain way so all
of those elements came into
consideration when we the first thing we
did was try to find the house these guys
they do something that at the end of the
day I I really think you become a
theater troupe they we got together and
they handed us journals and we we wrote
in these journals they asked us a bunch
of questions and we wrote about
ourselves and we wrote about our
characters and everybody did this Zoe
Paul and that we would share our entries
with each other and very personal stuff
we played darts we listen to music
together we we ate together we ran
around the room together and by the end
of it you you have people like Paul and
I who knew each other very little don't
look much like each other and and your
brother's your brothers and in that that
kind of experience is so it's so rare at
least for me and it's so valuable and it
will be missed on the next film and the
next next until I could try to get back
together with them because it's it's
it's so it was so cool it was so fun